officers and visitors welcome to the
Audit Committee meeting at the temple
market 2020 and I think most of you if
not all of you will know the Chairman
council culture is a way stick so I will
be running a meeting I'm going to start
with the emergency evacuation
announcement should we be required to
even evacuate a building would you
please leave the building by the nearest
available exit there is one that fire
exit in this room if you need to
evacuate the room do so by the glass
door to the eternal external fire exit
staircase please hold both have
handrails in case the stairs are wet or
slippery if anyone is unable to use the
stairs but they please allow others to
exit the room before they go to the fire
escape door where they can then be given
to systems our assembly points will be
in the public carpark at the side of the
Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collecting for knowings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded and can I
please remind you to switch off your
mobile mobile phones or turn them on -
silence
apologies for absence we have to once
will be the Chairman's in LA butcher and
counselor employ and meticulous are
there any others Laurie kettle short mr.
Shaw I was attempting there are any
substitute members or members attending
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
December 2019
do I have your agreement to sign them as
agreed the Grail is thank you thank you
do any members have any declarations of
interest move them to the main item on
the agenda item 6 is the external audit
report and that will be thank you thank
you yes so this reports and sets out the
final audit was all supports for their
formation 2018-19
which was really the work to do because
committees attention then at the
beginning of December at which point the
audit having quiet concluded but was
essentially completed so we went through
the detail of that report at that time
since then members will be aware that
the audit was finally signed off just
before Christmas and the audit results
report and subsequently being updated
and their beats annuity pod on the world
run through that and in just a minute
just dropping and many changes and then
the 2018-19
let us which basically provides a
summary position of the key findings
that the result of the audit last year
and also appended to the report so the
cover report essentially just sets out
the process that we've been through and
a summary of the audio pinyin and you I
found and it also sets out the proposed
final fee for the audit work in the
natural year and I post and scarfie
variational Thunder 14,000 pounds has
been proposed and that's being reviewed
and agreed in principle by myself and
will be subject to public sector audit
appointments and reviewing that to make
sure it's reasonable
so the yeah the recommendation is that
the audit letter and the final audit
results and results won't be noted and
that I'll now hand over to me and thank
you I'll keep you fairly brief because
remember the committee will have been
taking through this report in quite a
lot of detail and we have the sound
rating so as nobody said with this two
documents attached the annual bit later
and also an updated ice 260 episodes
reports the annual letter is largely
repeat of the audit results report but
the intention is that difficulties so
the only audit matter is is written for
the council its publish on its website
and so that interested stakeholders can
read that and get a high-level picture
of the work that you're going to take
and during the year and the issuance of
these providers so it's hopefully with a
slightly more user friendly language
than the audit results report and a
slightly higher level if I take you
through that
best of all just in terms of the
executive summary so as we've noted
there we issues no qualified opinion or
financial statements
conclusion segments I guess the key
things that changed and we have known
from us to report in terms of any other
status responsibilities or any of the
other areas of work that we undertake so
I think overall a positive outcome for
the council as we noted we discussed the
audit results report itself in December
and where to finalize our issue and our
opinion and issued our audit report and
certificates on the 24th of December so
as a happy Christmas Eve present for all
those involved in the orbit so we do
want to take the opportunity to thank
the staff for the council for and their
continued support through our shoots
which was not the most straightforward
and obviously people working up to very
late deadlines to make sure we've got
the community before Christmas which was
the targets that we were aiming for and
I probably wasn't to say it a lot more
because I think everything in the annual
neglect it really repeats like I said
what we were fortunate results reporter
what I will just do it is drawing your
attention to probably a couple of things
that changed between the moment
presenter view results report to you and
the actual issue of the opinion so that
the main change was really in relation
to the cash flow statement where we
identified some areas of the cash most
damaged which the mayor mentioned the
final version and they are reported in
our objective results report and also
now have summary of all the differences
we also concluded on an issue which I
think the reporting firmly to this
committee which was where we had no
confirmation of an investment balance
which was not in reality and investment
balance of the council and it was it was
a very large sum and so we had to
resolve that and so there was a lot of
communication so much back to clarify
the assurances event managers guidance
panels which actually was part of a
general Milwaukee fund it wasn't a
specific to watch
to cancel so should not be provided to
us from Deutsche Bank so it took some
time to get to a resolution on that
point incentive lots of communication
then in terms of the assurances they
provided and I think the only of the
wheel uncertainty reported was the the
cash that the the council holds on
behalf of 186 monies for CCGs why there
was some I guess lack of clarity about
whether that should be mechanicals
account or not because it doesn't six
with CCG accounts and we reported it as
an uncertainty because it wasn't
material and we've been discussing us as
part of planning for this year in terms
of how that should be treated because
clearly it's not actually available to
the council to use so I think we've
agreed that a disclosure note would be
appropriate in a way that counts as
similar it is growing those trust funds
that they may hold cash for box of
Triscuits don't relate to any any funds
that the counselors available to use I
think as Naomi's already highlighted the
variation in related to additional work
we have to tackle 2008 to 19 on a
variety of issues that has been agreed
with officers and we noticeably - that's
PSA for approval probably wasn't to say
much more on the reports of the same
because they are largely repetitive of
each other and repetitive of the report
that came in December but obviously is
an opportunity for this committee to ask
any further questions they wanted
turning through a divorce at this point
but I think the key thing is we didn't
manage to complete the audit and issue
an unqualified opinion and all the
report before they pay 616 that very
first statement loose makes it look
extremely bad can you explain that place
not included about granted
okay so so basically that's just saying
that's what we set our materiality
levels at so I'm doing any order
we basically conclude what level of on
adjusted errors could and significantly
influence a reader or use of these
financial statements we said that
generally the percentage of gross
revenues spend and I'm going to use 2%
for your audits and so that's just
reporting the level that we undertake
hold it went to and therefore the
assurance that it provides you with so
our audit is planned to detect errors of
727 million to do that we said we
actually perform our procedures at a
lower level so that's our performance
materiality level so we build the
tolerance in to that in effect so we
undertake our procedures looking for
errors of three five two million so that
builds in a bucket in effect between the
assurance that were providing it point
seven million and then where we actually
need to take our work using a lower
level to provide that assurance so
that's not saying that's the level of
error in the council's accounts that's
saying that we determined that that's
the level which would implement some of
the accounts and that's what we decide
on all the procedures to just provide
assurance over it's just the word it's
going Li we determined a magnitude of
uncollected misstatements and that is
because that's what we judge and we drew
them either individually or collectively
so if we will know where smaller ones
and they build up to that materiality
level then we would have an issue in
terms so you know maybe we can't be
looked at in well I think the point in
as Debbie said is that that that that's
the level that we would be judged by so
it's a benchmark that we measured
against it's not saying that they have
found errors of that level of
materiality in our accounts it's just
that's the level at which we are judged
against in terms of whether it's a
material or an important sort of change
that would need to be made to our
accounts to reflect that so yeah it's
not that I have actually found that
level of error in our accounts does that
make sense
no wording still worries me so determine
the magnitude on correcting missed
payments that we judge from would be
material for the financial statements as
a whole site I accept that you could
sort it for the experience in terms
I use or read and interpret that but
that's not the intention to say that
there is because that it seems to be
implying that there is so there is not I
practically threw their shoes and we can
look at that wording when we report and
actually I I can see what you're saying
when you read that so we will then have
a look at that wording that's fairly
standard working the use but I can see
how it could be interpreted differently
thank you I think German obviously the
fact that you were still putting this
report together on Christmas a evil
there guy got the impression when we had
our previous meetings that we were
struggling we roll we were struggling to
meet some of the deadlines that have
recently been imposed by central
government one thing other are we
confident that you know we we've done
everything and we're as much it up in
advance for next year's figures as as we
can be or is there any action that we
should take to make sure that we do I
mean the deadlines easier or I'm not
pushing it to the boundaries should we
say so and the deadlines for the
completing the accounts for us as a
council hasn't changed from last year so
we're still working to the deadline at
the end of May and we've got an audio
timetable in place to make sure we
achieve that that's you know quite
finding our own level of detail terms of
the tasks have to be caught up to hit
that deadline we did meet that deadline
last year we had big yeah Grant County
ready and published on the website by
that point in time so I'm reasonably
confident that we've got their creep
who's awesome
you never laugh that we were still about
to achieve that for this yes that's the
first part and then the second part is
then after that deadline they didn't
have to be audited and that's the bit
obviously then stretch it out a bit lost
the order yeah yeah so now it said last
year obviously we we didn't have
challenges meeting the we call it a
deadline you can sonority regulations
but I think they went through this at
the community in this area requires out
of the order to declare to be published
or a notice he's saying that the order
has a window and why obviously we work
we tried to do what we could by the end
of July the council's come for service
accounts but we are physically not able
to do all of our all the clients within
a two-month window in effect and we're
not the only thing to be in that
position again I think it discussed this
year I think up from we are scheduling
to be completely to be doing our audits
prolong the period so we are scheduling
some to be done in June some May June
July August September October so we are
scheduling audits through that whole
period and so got what certainly not all
over all is done by the end of July in
terms of the decisions we've made as to
who goes in which phase there it's quite
a complicated process in terms of
deciding which kind of Z which
particular they think of that some of it
reflects where we've got significant
challenges so some audits we still
haven't signed off for 1819 so obviously
those orders will be going later because
mr. bickerman dear previous year let's
look at it other ones we then know left
with a residual pool of basically what
we call all of our councils that kind of
you know we don't have any specific
issues with and ideally we would like to
do them all in a June July period with
physical cants so then it's about our
available resources so when how many
audits do the managers have any orders
the seniors have went
schedule at work so we can prune the
right team with a consistent set and get
it done a reason block of time because I
think the problem we had here like she
was it's three day for a very long time
to interact on which was very disruptive
I think it's the counselor 12 so we've
looked at Thomas this year and this year
we are I am to remember the exact dates
but we certainly before the end of
geologic yeah just like junior yeah so
you are in that block this year doing
anyone I think that we flex and I said
partly our availability of the right
resources to put in that fits within
that time frame and also the fact that I
think we we saw a lot less errors in
last year's account and we have two
previously which I think gives us the
comfort that we can get that audit done
in a tight timeframe based on our
experience in actually carrying the
finance team in Miami
just come back I mean I've just got down
here pretty good report having listened
to some of these albeit reports over the
years we've had some red flags flying up
and quite quickly and I thought having
seen this and gone through this and
listening to your other comment I think
we seem to have turned a corner on these
audit reports and things with you know
the officers and staff have done a good
job and presented the stuff for you in a
in a very good and correct manner but
you know I'll leave you to answer that
way the only way very well not fair to
say from the point of view of the
responsiveness and the quality of the
responses to queries and the working
papers and there are a few areas that we
can improve on both sides for this
already so as I say we're confident we
can get this already done in a sort of
short sharp audit window thank you okay
okay any other Thank You chairman yes
he's great to see an unqualified report
because that's that's what you want to
see just a question I'm looking at a 649
and it's the land of billion building
valuation and you mentioned that plate
was applied to me to the valuations and
in a venue now it's about an index can I
just ask what sort of index we're
looking at and is that a common thing
for all councils to look at that
indexing relating to learnability values
it's very common and it's we would
expect it to be honest
so councils requirement to keep their
land and building valuations materially
up to date and after I teach you here
the balance sheet dates and one of the
code however they're not were quite you
know to a full physical valuation of
those assets every year there is a
requirement to do that under within a
five-year period
so the valuations don't get out of date
however due to the movements in London
building valuations we do expected
properties have a being revalued
physically so even your value hasn't
been inspected them that there would be
some kind of desktop indexation applied
to make sure those valuations don't get
out of date in a five year cycle and
quite often councils will we value their
largest assets every year to make sure
that doesn't happen but it's still in
residual population that we have to
assess and say although still material
accurate and so they would be depending
on the nature of the asset but there's
lots of indices that you can get from
sort of value and websites that were
taking you so I mean residential
properties an easy one because you can
look at that but there are lots of sales
tables that you can produce
so generally any advice and value is
that producing with emotions where else
but me they provide national indices
that come down to a geographical area
and we can use those to compare against
the indices of those only was used so
that they're out there produced by you
know but the value is exactly and market
information basically of expensive
properties right so it's a normal thing
so did you say there's only buddy W five
years and we did change our accounting
policy and year or so back because we
were having are all on addresses
yeah probably we valued every year
yeah we're now seeing on a five-year
cycle saw yes it yeah we probably would
not eat like that cycle and then between
that that's that said we are a fabulous
room we use what resonates them
I am indexation basting the other
property values to comply of a criteria
one last one if I may through you German
I mean when we're looking at that I we
talked me about all the assets that we
have I would be stripped of land if you
like that we actually owe because
clearly in some cases there will be
strips might be read some strips or
whatever and it's what's applied to that
but it's what material value it has at
the time you don't want yeah well some
are asset which the shoe cover or every
asset that counsel I'd say she has
complete coverage of all assets and then
says different potential ways that are
valued or indices and depending on what
kind of asset is but yes the accounts
aren't she should reflect everything
where else in the area okay thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
any other questions to source the
quality of diversity on item six five
point one and it have been completed but
you know
yep
probably not worth it definitely well
but essentially I think what we're
saying is that we saw this or a desktop
evaluation to say would there be any
equality impacts as a result of the
report and understand if there isn't any
impact on their policies as a result of
the audit report so it's not gonna
impact long protected group you know
more then another decision was made it
was um it was decided I think those
decisions be made in relation to this
report okay also add seasoning
information I don't know yeah
just one question really on 635 it's a
bullet point there's no to the variance
between the council in general they just
ledger another line that is winter of
45,000 bonds of my compound which was
fifty four thousand seven I'm a
volunteer management should review the
root cause of the difference in
corrective twenty ninth twenty nine
twenty I mean the dress what's the
general call that most the next bullet
point is one about the general ledger
for underlying Housing Benefit debtors
for those I think there's a second point
we we know if we understand the reason
for that is very timely difference
between reports the first one I don't
think is necessary due to its having it
so we don't know why the reason for it
which is why we for the same counsel
should look into it because he just
seemed to build huge Rico's every year
so that's an underlying top
- why that's I'm not reconciling they're
not material differences but they should
reconcile so it's better understanding
the reason for that big door well that
is an ongoing piece of work which is
being and I think we have made some
progress but I'm I think because this
decides I'm happened over a number of
years then so with digging into real
world that taking an amount of time but
it's certainly something new is being
actively pursued carrying the team to
make sure on the weekend through Genesis
mirror a focus for that will come up to
next year as well it will be consumed it
will continue to be looked at because
it's ever experienced being practiced
yes I mean we we'd always look at the
records part of our standard procedures
is reconciling general ledger to the
possible edges so if there's any
differences between those we obviously
look at them if they're more material we
were training together materials that
will be appearing as a significant risk
I um but we would obviously pick it up
it's bonus just in place they just
inflated interests
before we get too excited okay members
in the absence of any further reference
the moved to the foundation which is
that the annual audience pleasure for
the year ended 31st March 2019 and the
final audit results report for 2018
stroke 19 feed notice as noted members
item 7 is the audit thank you can ask
members to turn to 71 for p.m. a report
provides members with an update of the
work the internal audit team six of us
reported back in November the team
Jimin Becker been very busy since that
November haven't completed a further
nine Audion gage Minh
was rated as good five adequate and well
limited and no kidding was provided
we've gone to nine types of audit
engagements a total of thirteen new
recommendations have been raised I'll
talk about the limited audience and
that's in relation to debt management so
Thibault can ask members to turn to 7.13
so this provides members with an extract
of the findings from a Nordic report in
relation to debt management the problem
is about Berlin sort of relying on a
single individual to manage the process
this is not really helped by the fact
that the tether system merely raises
invoices is not actual a better
management system in itself so it's the
whole process in terms of them sends out
reminder letters and managing the debt
is a manual process and that information
is contained on a spreadsheet so system
yourself doesn't remind the individual
that we need to run raised reminders so
we rely on this individual to ensure
their spreadsheets up-to-date regards
the information around bed so we're
solely reliant on a spreadsheet and is
this individual form engine I bet that
said that the number of deaths we
actually raised caught this quite a few
so it could be argued do we need any
moving more robust than a spreadsheet to
manage our deaths I mean we don't have a
large number of deaths we don't raise a
large number of Isis but so do we need a
fancy debt management system to do that
so but we did find some some issues
around debt management yourself and so
the best system does not even automate
your debt management function so
progression stages are process manually
yong-go monitoring of invoices has not
been effective diary thanks for
progression a big effort has been missed
so there are there are a number of
issues raised in relation to having such
Romanian process and this report that
goes a long way to addressing some issue
so identifiers so that's that's the the
audience a bit include assurance pinning
me penny for debtors further the report
brings two members attention changes to
the audit plan I'm required to UM
friendly to members attention changes to
the autoplay so what I provided that
appendix for is a copy the audit plans
for 2019 nine 2019-20 say [ __ ] our
members through turn to 7.30
so we have a copy the audit plan for
2019-20 and one-up tends to do so
highlighting members all the audits in
the audit plan for the nineteen twenty
and a progress update in terms of where
we are currently
so as members will see from underneath
the appendix for that the majority of
audits have been completed for the year
there are some words that are still in
progress and there are a couple of audit
priority one other words that we will
not undertake this year so these will be
deferred until 2021 but in essence the
majority the audit plan will be
delivered by the end of the year the
audit plan itself is essentially just a
program of work for the forthcoming year
and what the only plans about is at
least of audits that I will undertake or
provide that assurance on the council's
arrangements for risk management
governments and internal control I'm
required to provide an annual opinion so
you get from me I think it's in in May
an annual report which provides them on
their opinion on their councils
arrangements as I said for risk
management governments to control so I
have to undertake a series of audience
to actually get to an opinion and what
we do we consider audience in terms of
them there are a number of priority one
what is that I will undertake because
they give me a wider assurance and the
council's Duren arrangements so in terms
of these these are all this I I suppose
you must undertake so we look at the
council's Ethernet for systems and this
would give me an opinion of the
arrangements for financial management
and then this all is we call priority to
audits these are all these that will not
necessarily affect my opinion year end
but the audience that actually we are
undertaking and behalf of service
departments I mean when I find my main
five areas for improvement but ended
they they're not going to cause me
concern because
these are these are areas with so that
thumbs take on part of a service
management and we may identify areas for
improvement but it's not going to
materially affect my opinion year-end so
there have been changes to the audit
plan and there is a status update
provided so there are as I saved the
plan itself is a fluid item so there
will be changes to the plan gender
course of a year and these these mainly
due to new or emerging risks it might be
due to this may actually an audit we
planned at the start of year we can no
longer under tank or start a you excited
unstable but there's been changes in the
service department so no longer makes
the audit by all is no point in ferment
or it right now I will come back a look
at it and at the time so there will be
changes to the audit plan during the
course of the year so this is just
bringing two members attention that
these the alerts we cleanse due back at
starter yet but there have been changes
to the already plan but the changes will
not affect my overall opinion and urine
so that's just to give some human
remember some assurance that there are
some warnings we want on the tank but
it's not going to affect my opinion your
in because we would have done sufficient
work by that time I mean provided if any
to you progress after they've also been
talks about can't the fraud activity so
I'm just going to highlight some of the
headlines horizon for network so in
terms of count forward activity much of
the work in terms of these areas
undertaking player compliance officer
focus on who sits to resin bent so that
so the headlines so we have achieved
cashable savings in relation to council
tax in the region of seventy four
thousand pounds and this is arising from
new bills that been sent out that
customers haven't been paying council
we identify new people on the ratings
list and also in Renekton relations
would feel of discounsel exceptions that
no longer apply so from that work were
then apply cash as I say cash it will
say you mean successor sentence four
thousand pounds the compliance officers
always an undertaking in some proactive
work we've been there in business rings
again we've raised bills with properties
that were not on the ratings list and
this is to the value of six hundred
forty nine thousand pound and also where
some of the business of applying for
basically small business rate relief
what we all have identified but actually
they also cleanly small business rate
relief on another business in another
area and you're not allowed to apply it
more than once so basically we were made
adjustments about so in terms of those
two savings savings are arising from
small business really that's to the
value of fourteen thousand fast again a
fervor catchable savings fought back to
the authority we also done state work in
relation to benefits overpayments and
housing benefits and we've identified
Housing Benefit overpayments as a venue
for thirty seven thousand town again
additional cash all savings back to the
authority we've actually investigate
hasn't benefit fraud that now for was to
Department for Work attention so that's
not something we now investigate
lastly the arm the report deals with
recommendations or recommendations it's
not very much to stake in relation to
audit recommendations apart from good
progress has been made by management in
implementing audit recommendations
there's only a total of thirteen live
recommendations at the moment so so
there's only a small number of already
recommendations and loans currently
outstanding and a community cause only
three of the would is sort of the
recommendations have resulted in amended
implementation things and were aware the
reasons for that so we are in constant
dialogue with service department
to identify what progress is being made
in relation to implementation of order
recommendations and it's Jim and Becky's
job to chase those and managers and
progress up place to understand actually
where we're at and only essentially in
exceptional circumstances with all the
implementation things being moved
there's got to be good reason why those
things have been changed I'm quite happy
to take any questions in relation to my
report I think if the comments you made
right at the start regarding the manual
system that we have initiative probably
directive more and I army than the new
yourself will the new transition
computer system assist in this will it
be part of it or will this still be
outside of that area of operation and I
suppose the second question is Oh
is it sufficient enough that we should
be addressing it as I as a priority or
or or is it something we are happy to
live with yeah and I think as you've
identified it's also something that's
given me a bit of a cause for concern
and reflection and obviously we want to
optimize our debt recovery function and
it is one of our key sort of them
financial processes that we carry out as
we've loaded to actually the number of
debts we have is relatively low so I
think any solution that we implement has
to be proportionate and obviously we
don't want to spend some hundreds of
thousands of pounds on systems to
address something that's you know
relatively small issue but I think
certainly as part of the connect program
which I think perhaps what you're
alluding to in terms of the
transformation and there is an area that
I'm certainly I wouldn't be looking at
as scoping out whether there is a
potential solution as part of that
program that could be identified and
implemented which would be yeah
proportionate in terms of the payback in
terms of the benefit under the
most of implement in our solution I
think as we also need to chew that
there's actually some controls in terms
of the resources in place and making
sure that people doing their jobs
properly which will actually yield some
of the benefits of that as well so I
think well we've had some transitional
resource or change of personnel within
the team and perhaps they haven't been
as obstacle dissapoint like and that's
sort of certainly picked up as part of
the order if we can put those controls
in place that will go some way to
addressing the concerns but yeah if we
if there is an electronic solution which
would save that some sort of a perm you
do see potential human error then
certainly that's something that I think
yeah we would consider over the next
sort of year you're also to make sure
that the bus and those these issues that
arise I'm going forward but I am
confident that the recommendations that
have been raised have being implemented
or are being implemented at them so in
thinking the short term we've got some
assurance that the immediate issues are
being addressed but the other side more
than happy you didn't appear to thank
you understanding stop I've started to
do some work if I'm actually seen
someone try man named a delta tomorrow
to go through some of the initial
discussion points so they'll be a
reportedly makes one committed that's
what I I would have thought that would
just kind of tied in with the PCP
planning business resilience where we've
seen like with red car red car
council that I've had a cybersecurity
attack and they say yeah so is that
going to be looked at in Zoar
openly IT security will be business
resilience sewing the issue with the
server room last year which caused
problem then that's part of our
discussions and the action plan arising
from the inspection that was carried out
this is continuity we'll be looking at
me more about the arrangements for
initiating any plans but it's a
cybersecurity order we'll be looking
specifically at defenses against now
we're in such fun thanks Alko thank you
very much cheering can I just ask
as far as reporting to members where
you've got them digits or no shorts
you've gone through and you've said that
there are areas where there are you know
shorts and you're happy visit but do you
give a report to the committee to say
which of those are like that and how
long we've been going for sort of report
if you like how's it going so that we
know where those areas of we come back
in terms of I suppose progress updates
those recommendations against that
looted audio so we will bring back to
committee we may do a follow up we tend
to do a follow up in relation to limited
audience so we will do that audio again
next year and be able to provide members
with an update in terms actually what
progress is being made against those
recommendations and whether moved from a
limitation or 22 adequate or good so
yeah we've got those those the audits
where a limited shorts reason to be
provided we will pull her up and bring
it back to committee and same progress
is being made in relation to that okay
just through YouTube nothing is please
avail unleash it by the committee where
you've got those problems if you like to
make sure that they a flag up what we've
got any reason to discern and make sure
indeed that that works being done to
appreciate your site needs done but we
don't know it's done
you know that's yeah boy that make yeah
everybody spoke back in terms of a
progress update so I'll follow up audit
so
gaining sense island ship we will come
back to committee and explain to you
what progress has been made that's the
person thank you the more questions so
I'll go to the recommendation on page
seven point two
I'll take them individually it is
proposed the Commissioner tells the
update on that delivery 15 2019 spoke 20
order that we noted is that agreed
agreed
secondly that the conclusions and
results in impeaching orbital
engagements in the 20 seas 2 & 3 be
noticed as food
thirdly that an updated status of the
2019 spoke 20 annual audit plan appendix
14 heritage doesn't read written green
and finally that the updated note so I
start again that the updated status of
audience recommendations in appendix 5
be noted that group members now Gregory
doing yep thank you please
finalize what the agenda like thank you
by falling on the ceiling and restless
thank you all for attending
you